لكن ليست دعم العسكري فقط هو ما يؤرق
روسيا وانما ايضا حزمه العقوبات الاوروبيه
المفروضه عليها فالحرب الاقتصاديه بين
روسيا والغرب تشتد وتدخل منعرجا حاسما
خاصه فيما يتعلق بعصب الاقتصاد الروسي
صادرات الطاقه منذ بدايه هذا اليوم دخلت
حزمه عقوبات اوروبيه وغربيه حيزه تنفيذ
وتستهدف حظر مشتقات الوقود الروسيه ضمن
جهود لخفض المداخيل الماليه لموسكو وتشمل
هذه العقوبات تحديدا سقف سعر الاضافي على
المنتجات البتروليه الروسيه
سقف اسعار المنتجات البترونيه ذات الجوده
العاليه
هو 100 دولار للبرميل
اما المنتجات البتروليه الاخرى مثل زيت
الوقود والنفته فان سقف سعرها اصبح خمسه
واربعين دولارا للبرميل وتعني هذه العقوبه
ان اي دوله تسعى لشراء النفط الروسي لن
تكون قادره على القيام بذلك الا اذا دفعت
اقل من الحد الاقصى كما ان الشركات
الاوروبيه والبريطانيه لن تقوم بتامين اي
شحنه لا تستجيب لهذا الشرط وضع جديد
تواجهه روسيا الان التي ستحتاج الى البحث
عن مشترين بدلاء لما يقرب من 600 الف
برميل كانت ترسلها سابقا الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي يوميا بالاضافه الى البحث عن
اساطير بديله لنقل الشحن بعد توقف تعاملها
مع السفن الغربيه لنقل تلك الشحن وقد تخسر
روسيا
160 مليون يورو يوميا وذلك بحسب تصريحات
رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه اورسو لافندرلين
لكن من شان العقوبات الاخيره ان تنعكس
سلبا على السوق الاوروبيه خاصه وان اوروبا
تحصل على اكثر من نصف وارداتها من الديزل
من روسيا ولم تجد امدادات كافيه حتى الان
ما قد يؤدي الى ارتفاع الاسعار هذه دهوك
معه المزيد من باريس
يعيش الفرنسيون قلقا مستمرا من حدوث ازمه
وقود في البلاد هذا القلق نابع بالدرجه
الاولى من تهديد النقبات باضرابات ستشمل
حقول الضخ ما سيعطل حركه تزويد المحطات
بالوقود هذه الاضرابات تاتي في سياق
اقتصادي ضاغط فرضته الحرب في اوكرانيا ما
تسبب بزياده الاسعار وزياده نسب التضخم اذ
قفزت اسعار المواد البتروليه الى ارقام
غير مسبوقه فاقترب سعر لتر الديزل على
سبيل المثال الى اليوروهين والنصف
الحكومه تدخلت في السابق لخفض الاسعار لكن
ذلك كان لمده انقضت مع نهايه العام 2022
اما الان فهناك مساعده بدات الحكومه
بدفعها لاصحاب الدخل المحدود من اولئك
الذين يستخدمون سياراتهم في الذهاب الى
العمل فادي الداهوك العربيه باريس
العقوبات الغربيه تواصل تشديد الخناق على
روسيا لحرمانها من تمويل عملياتها
العسكريه لكن كما نجحت موسكو في الالتفاف
على الحزم السابقه تحاول التغلب على الحزم
الجديده بمساعده اطراف عده ومن بينها
الصين نقلا عن تقرير لصحيفه وست جارنا
الامريكيه فان الصين باتت مصدرا مزودا
لروسيا بعده مكونات لم تعد تصلها بسبب
العقوبات خاصه المواد ذات الاستخدام
العسكري في الصين تقدم تكنولوجيا الحربيه
التي يحتاجها الجيش الروسي وذلك نقلا عن
بيانات الجمارك الروسيه التي حصلت عليها
الصحيفه تظهر السجلات الجمركيه ان شركات
الدفاع الصينيه المملوكه للدوله تشحن
معدات الملاحه وقطع الغيار للطائرات
المقاتله الى شركات الدفاع المملوكه
للحكومه الروسيه والخاضعه للعقوبات كما هو
معلوم
ومن بين الشحنات قطع غيار ارسلت الى شركه
تصنيع الصواريخ الروسيه المملوكه للدوله
الماز انتي وتظهر في البيانات ايضا شحنات
من المسيرات الصينيه والتي يقول دي جي اي
محللون عسكريون ان القوات الروسيه
تستخدمها لتحديد موقع القوات
الاوكرانيهما حيث اكتفت روسيا بالقول ان
لديها امكانات تكنولوجيه كافيه لضمان
امنها وتامين العمليه العسكريه الخاصه
وذلك نقلا عن المتحدث باسم الكرملين
اما الصين فقد ردت على لسان المتحدث باسم
سفارتها في واشنطن
ان الادعاء بان الصين تقدم مساعدات لروسيا
ليس له اساس واقعي وهو مجرد تكهنات وتضخيم
متعمد
ورغبه في وقف هذه المساعدات الصينيه قالت
واشنطن انها بصدد تجهيز عقوبات ضد اهداف
جديده يعتقد انها تسهل حرب الكرملين وياتي
ملف دعم الصين لروسيا ليضاف الى الملفات
الاخرى التي تشعل التوتر بين بكين وواشنطن
علما انه كان من المقرر مناقشه هذا الملف
خلال زياره
التي اجلت بسبب حادثه المنطاد الصيني وهو
موضوعنا الاول في العربيه 360